filas interminables de conductores
desesperados por llegar a un lugar
seguro miles de residentes del suroeste
del estado de Alberta buscan huir de las
llamas y acatar la orden de evacuación
emitida por las autoridades mientras un
feroz incendio se acerca a zonas
residenciales
o se hayan ido
estoy un poco ansioso por lo que pase Y
como estaba todo cuando volvamos
no sé si nuestra casa todavía estará
allí mañana no lo sé
en el Horizonte la manta de humo opaco
solo se hace más grande la provincia
occidental de Canadá ha estado en llamas
Durante los últimos días 25.000 personas
ya han tenido que huir de sus hogares
algunas incluso teniendo que conducir a
través de las llamas Los Fuertes vientos
hacen que los incendios forestales
continúen avanzando en el suelo seco y
boscoso incluso amenazando las
operaciones de extracción de petróleo en
la región las autoridades locales han
declarado el estado de emergencia
actualmente hay 103 incendios forestales
activos en Alberta que queman
121.909 hectáreas y desde ayer ha habido
35 nuevos incendios forestales a pesar
del despliegue de los cuerpos de Socorro
un tercio de los incendios siguen fuera
de control debido a las altas
temperaturas que se están presentando
durante esta temporada de primavera en
Alberta de 10 a 15 grados centígrados
por encima de lo normal